joe biden has not made any sense for a
very long time he was asked this is
almost sad if the guy weren't sort of
hobbling along
half trying to pretend to be president
and and run our lives for us
i would feel pretty bad for the guy he
was just asked about what's going on in
israel and the palestinian territories
right now
and if you can make sense of his answer
please
leave leave the uh translation in the
comment section because i can't quite
make heads or tales of it
i had a brief conversation with them
yesterday
and i have my
my intelligence community the
defense department as well as
the state department have been in
contact with all of their counterparts
in
not only in israel but in the region and
one of the things that i have seen thus
far
is that there has not been
a significant overreaction the question
is how
how we get to a point where they get to
a point where
there is a significant reduction
in the attacks particularly
the rocket attacks that are
indiscriminately
fired into population centers i've been
looking at the
in israel they had people
there firing there and i looked and i
talked to
what happened the guy is clearly not up
to the job and
you see it reflected in his foreign
policy by the way i i'm under no
misapprehension that joe biden is
actually running things over there
but the people that he's empowered are
just as exhausted as he is maybe not
physically
but ideologically they're just returning
to the same
exact middle eastern strategy that
failed for decades and decades and
decades to bring about any semblance of
peace
then trump comes in completely upends
that
that policy and doubles the number of
arab countries that that have recognized
israel
and gets two historic peace deals
and then what happened biden comes in
and it's the same zombie
president in the same zombie government
with the same zombie policies giving us
if it feels like uh night of the walking
dead or something like that
nope not so fast you know you know what
you got to do
come on don't make me say it you got to
ring the bell
you got to ring the bell you got to
subscribe you got to like that is how
you will get notifications so that i can
see you on the next
video
[Music]
[Music]